The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: So
today we're going
to go from the classical
mechanical treatment
of the harmonic oscillator to
a quantum mechanical treatment.
And I warn you that
I intentionally
am going to make this
look bad, because
the semi-classical approach
at the end of this lecture
will make it all really simple.
And then on Monday
I'll introduce
creation and
annihilation operators,
which makes the harmonic
oscillator simpler
than the particle in a box.
You can't believe
that, but all right.
So last time we treated the
harmonic oscillator classically
and so we derive the equation
of motion from forces
equal to mass times
acceleration, and we solved it.
And we saw that we have this
quantity omega, which initially
I just introduced
as a constant, which
was a way of combining the
force constant and the mass.
And then I showed that
the period of oscillation
is 1 over the frequency,
which is 2 pi over omega.
Now one of the
things that people
have trouble remembering
under exam pressure
is turning points.
And this comes
when the energy is
equal to the potential
at a turning point.
And since the
potential is 1/2 kx
squared we get the equation
for the turning point
at a given energy, which
is equal to plus or minus
the square root of 2e/k.
Now when you're
drawing pictures there
are certain things that
anchor the pictures,
like turning points.
And now at the end of
the previous lecture
I calculated the classical
mechanical average,
and we use we use
this kind of notation
in classical mechanics.
Sometimes we use
this notation, too,
but this is what we mean by
the average value in quantum
mechanics.
And we found that this was
the total energy divided by 2.
And the average momentum
is the energy divided by 2.
And that's the basis
for some insight,
because as a harmonic
oscillator moves
it throws energy back and
forth between kinetic energy
and potential energy.
And then one of my
favorite things,
and one of my favorite
tortures on short answers,
is the average values of--
And does anybody want to
remind the class the easy way,
or the two easy ways
to know what this is?
And the person who answered
the question last time
is disqualified.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: There is
the symmetry method.
ROBERT FIELD: What?
AUDIENCE: There's symmetry.
So if the system's symmetrical
that the average value will
actually be that symmetry point.
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
So and the other is that
the harmonic oscillator
isn't moving, and so there is
no way that the coordinate--
that the average value of either
the coordinate or the momentum
could be different from 0.
However you do it you
want to be doing it
in seconds, not minutes.
And certainly not by
calculating integral.
And now x squared and p
squared, they're easy too.
Especially if you know t and
v. And so we then use those
to calculate the variance.
And that's defined
as the average value
of the square minus the square
of the average square root.
And what we find is
that the variance
of x times the variance of
p is equal to e over omega.
So as you go up in energy this
joint uncertainty increases.
And we'll find that that also
is true for quantum mechanics.
So this is sort of
the kind of questions
you want to be asking
in quantum mechanics.
And you want to be
able to be guided
by what you know from
classical mechanics,
and you want to be
able to do it fast.
Today's menu is
what I would call--
This lecture is
gratuitous complexity.
Does everybody know
what gratuitous means?
This is one of my
favorite Bobisms.
And you'll hear other
Bobisms during the course
of this course.
What I want you to be
able to do for a lot
of mechanical problems
is to know the answer,
or know what things look like
without doing a calculation.
In particular, not solving
a differential equation
or evaluating in the integrals.
You want to be able to draw
these pictures instantly.
Now in the modern age
everyone has a cell phone,
and one could have
a program in there
to calculate what anything you
wanted for harmonic oscillator.
But chances are you won't
be prepared for that.
And if you want to have insights
into how do various things
you want to know about harmonic
oscillators come about?
You need the
pictures, as opposed
to the computer program.
Now the pictures involve an
advance investment of energy.
You want to understand
every detail
of these little pictures.
I'm going to write
this runner equation,
I'm going to clean it
up to get rid of units
which makes it universal.
So it becomes a
dimensionless equation.
And the unit removal,
or the thing that
takes you from a specific
problem where there's
a particular force constant
and a particular reduced mass,
and makes it into
a general problem.
There is one or two constants
that combine those things.
And you've taken them out
at the end of a calculation.
If you need to have real units
you can put those back in.
And that's a very
wonderful thing,
and that enables
us to draw pictures
without thinking about,
what is the problem?
And then the solution of
this differential equation--
which is actually quite an awful
differential equation at least
for people who are
not mathematicians--
and the solution
can be expressed
as the product of
a Gaussian function
which goes to 0 at plus and
minus infinity, so it makes
the function well behaved.
Times something that
produces nodes, a polynomial.
Does anyone want to give me
a definition of a polynomial?
Silence.
OK, your turn.
AUDIENCE: It's the linear
combination of some numbers
taken to different power
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
A sum of integer
powers of a variable.
And when we take a
derivative of a polynomial
we reduce the order
of the polynomial.
A little bit of thought,
if you have a first order
polynomial there'll be one node.
If there is a second order
there'll be two nodes.
And nodes are very important.
And so when we're going to
be dealing with cartoons
of the wave function, and then
using semi-classical ideas
to actually semi-calculate
things that you'd want to know,
the nodes are really important.
And what's going
to happen Monday
is we'll throw away
all this garbage
and we will replace
everything by these creation
and annihilation operators.
Which do have really
simple properties,
which you can use
to do astonishingly
complicated things
without breaking a sweat.
And the final exam is in this
room on the first day of exam
period, at least
it's on a Monday,
and it's in the afternoon.
In the non-lecture
part of the notes
I replaced the mass for
one mass on a spring
by the reduced mass, which is
m1 m2 over m1 plus m2 for two
masses connected by a spring.
And I go back and forth between
using mu and m, and that's OK.
All right so in the notes
the differential equations
in the first few
pages are expressed
as partial
differential equations.
They're total
That'll get changed.
The Hamiltonian is t plus
v, and in the usual form t
is p squared over 2 mu.
And so we get minus h-bar
squared over 2 mu par--
not partial, I'm so
used to writing partials
that I can't stop.
Second derivative with respect
to x, plus 1/2 kx squared.
So that's the Hamiltonian.
Now that looks kind of
innocent, but it isn't.
And so the first
thing we want to do
is get rid of the
dimensionality, the units.
So this is xi and it's
defined as square root
of alpha times x.
Where alpha is defined as k
mu square root over h-bar.
Now it would be a perfectly
reasonable exam question
for you to prove that if
I take this combination
of physical quantities this
will have dimension of 1
over length.
That makes xi a
dimensionless quantity.
I'm not even going to bother
going through the derivation.
The Hamiltonian becomes
h-bar of omega times 2,
minus second derivative with
respect to xi plus xi squared.
So this is now dimensionless.
This has units.
We divide by h-bar omega to make
now everything dimensionless.
And we get a
differential equation
that has the form minus the
second derivative with respect
xi plus xi squared, minus
2e over h-bar omega,
times the wave function,
expressive function of xi,
not x.
This is the differential
equation we want to solve,
and we don't do that in 5.61.
You're never going to be
asked to solve a differential
equation like this.
But you're certainly
going to be asked
to understand what the
solution looks like,
and perhaps that it
is in fact a solution.
But that's still pretty
high value stuff,
though you wouldn't
really have to do that.
This is the simplest way
of writing the differential
equation and it's dimensionless.
The standard way of dealing
with many differential equations
is to say, OK, we
have some function
and it's going to be written
as an exponential, a Gaussian,
times some new function.
And for quantum mechanics
this is perfectly reasonable
because we have a
function in a well
and the wave functions have to
go to 0 at plus minus infinity.
And this thing goes to zero at
plus and minus infinity pretty
strongly.
So it's a good way
of building in some
of the expected behavior
of the solution.
And that's perfectly
legal, and it just
then defines what is the
difference equation remaining
for this?
And it turns out,
well we're going
to get the Hermite equation.
And this will be a Hermite
polynomial, the solutions.
Now one way of dealing with
this is to simply say, well,
we know the solution of
this differential equation
if this term weren't there.
Because this is now the
equation for a Gaussian.
So building in a Gaussian
as a factor in the solution,
it's a perfectly
reasonable thing.
And then we have to say,
what happens now when
we put this term back in?
And when we do we
get this thing.
Second derivative with
respect to this polynomial--
I mean of this polynomial
is equal to minus 2 xi times
the hn d xi plus 2n hn.
This is a famous differential
equation, the Hermite equation,
which is of no interest to us.
And it generates the
Hermite polynomials.
These things are the
And they are treated in
some kind of sacred manner
in most of the
textbooks, and I think
that's really an offense
because, well, we're
not interested in
mathematical functions.
We're interested in
insight and this is just
putting up another barrier.
Now with this equation, you
can derive two things called
recursion relations,
and one of them
is the derivative of this
polynomial with respect to xi
is equal to 2n times
hn minus 1 of xi.
Now that's not a surprise,
because this is a polynomial.
If you take a derivative
of the variable
you're going to reduce the
power of each term by 1.
Now it just happens to be lucky
that when we reduce it to 1
you don't get a sum of
many different lower order
polynomials, you just get 1.
And there is another one,
another recursive relation,
where it tells you if
you want to increase
the order you can do this,
you can multiply hn by xi.
And that's obviously-- it is
going to increase the order,
but it might not do it cleanly.
And it doesn't.
And so we get--
We have a relationship
between these three
different polynomials.
Now it turns out that
these two equations are
going to reappear, or
at least their progeny
will reappear, on Monday in
terms of raising and lowering
operators.
And what you intuit about
what happens if you multiply
polynomial by the variable?
Or what happens if you
take its derivative?
And it is very
simple and beautiful,
but I don't think this is very
beautiful for our purposes
as chemists.
And one of the things that these
recursive relationships do,
which also hints at
what's to come on Monday,
is that we can calculate
integrals like this.
That's not what I want.
This is a quantum
number, it's an integer.
It's v, not nu, and
multiply it by x to the n,
p to the m, psi that
should be complex
conjugated, v plus l, dx.
It turns out for
almost everything
we want to do with
harmonic oscillators
we're going to want to know
a lot of integrals like this.
And one of the things
we like is when
an integral is promised
to be 0 so we don't ever
have to look at it.
And so there are
selection rules.
And the selection rules
for this kind of integral
is l is equal to m plus
n, m plus n minus 2,
down to minus m plus n.
So the only possible non-zero
integrals of this form
are for the change
in quantum number
by this l, which goes from
m plus n down to minus m
plus n in steps of two.
The two shouldn't
be too surprising,
because there is
symmetry and we have
odd functions for
odd quantum numbers
and even functions for
even quantum numbers.
And so something
like this is going
to have a definite
symmetry and it's
going to change things
within a symmetry,
and so it's going to change the
selection rule in steps two.
Now you don't know what
selection rules are for,
or why you should get excited
about these sorts of things,
but it's really nice to know
that almost all the integrals
you are ever going to face for
a particular problem are zero.
And you can focus on a small
number of non-zero ones,
and it just turns out
that the non-zero ones
have really simple value.
There also exists what's called
a generating function, which
is the Rodriguez formula.
And that is the hn of xi is
equal to minus 1 to the n,
e to the psi squared, the
derivative with respect to xi,
e to minus xi squared.
We have one that has
a positive exponent,
and one has a negative
exponent, and we have this.
So we could calculate
any Hermite polynomial
using this formula,
which you will never do.
But it's treated with
great fanfare in textbooks.
Now the solution to the harmonic
oscillator wave function
in real units, as opposed to
dimensionless quantities, is--
and I'm just writing this down
because I never would ever
think about it this way, but
I have to at least provide you
with guidance--
so we have a factor 2 to
the v, again this is v.
Now the reason I'm emphasizing
this is that in all texts
v quantum numbers
are italicized.
And if you've thought about
it for a minute, an italic v--
for mortals-- looks like a nu.
It isn't quite.
I don't know what
the difference is,
but if you have them side
by side they are different.
And so a large number of
people who should know better
refer to the vibrational
quantum number as nu, which
marks that person
as, well, I won't
say but it's not complimentary!
We have this factor
to the square root,
and that's a normalization--
oh we got another part of it.
Alpha over pi to the 1/4 power.
So that's normalization.
Then we have the
Hermite polynomial.
And you notice I've
got xi back in here,
which is really a shame.
And we have--
So this is the
general solution, we
have the exponentially damped
function, we have polynomials.
These are all the
actors that we're
going to have to deal with.
And I promise you,
you will never
use this unless you want
to program a computer
to calculate the wave function
for God knows what reason.
The quantum numbers
we are 0, 1, 2.
And for a harmonic oscillator,
which goes to infinity,
v goes to infinity, too.
There's an infinite
number of eigenfunctions
of the quantum
mechanical Hamiltonian--
of quantum mechanical
harmonic oscillator.
We have-- and the
functions are normalized,
we have psi plus and
minus infinity goes to 0,
we have psi v of 0.
So this for all the--
I put a v there.
Psi v is 0 for odd v, derivative
of psi with respect to x, at x
equals 0 is 0 per even v. So
we have symmetric functions.
And we have the energy levels
is equal to h-bar omega, v
plus 1/2.
Now this is h over
2 pi, and this
is nu times 2 pi, the
frequency times 2 pi.
So it could also be h nu.
I have trouble remembering
when there is a 2 pi involved.
And we have this
wonderful thing.
It's as if v prime is equal
to v this integral is 1,
it's normalized.
And a v prime is not
equal to v, it's zero.
And that stems from a
theorem I mentioned before,
is if you have two eigenvalues
of the same Hamiltonian,
eigenfunctions of
the same Hamiltonian,
and they belong to
different eigenvalues
their overlap integral is 0.
We like zeros.
We like normalization because
the integral is just 1,
it goes away.
Or the integral is 0, the
whole thing goes away.
So that's really good.
So we call this set
of v's is orthonormal.
Orthogonal and normalized.
And the orthonormal
terminology is used a lot.
And in almost all quantum
mechanical problems
we like using an
orthonormal set of functions
to solve everything.
Sometimes we have to do a
little work to establish that,
and I'll show much
later in the course
how when you have functions
that are not orthogonal,
and not normalized,
you can create
a set of functions which are.
And this is something
that a computer will
do without breaking a sweat.
Now we're back to my favorite
topic, semi-classical.
Because it's really
easy to understand.
Not just to understand
the harmonic oscillator,
but to use it in many problems.
So in classic mechanics
the kinetic energy
is e minus v of x, or
p squared over 2 mu.
And so we can derive
an equation for p
of x classical mechanically,
which is 2 mu e
minus v of x square root.
This is an extremely
useful function.
It's not an operator.
It's a thing that
we're going to use
to make sense of everything,
but it's not an operator.
And so this is classic
mechanics, and then
in quantum mechanics, we know
that Mr. de Broglie told us
that the wavelength
is equal to h over p.
And we can generalize and say,
well, maybe the wavelength
is a function of
x for potential,
which is not constant.
And even though this is not an
operator in quantum mechanics
this is true.
That you can say the distance
between consecutive nodes
is lambda over 2.
We can use this
node relationship
to great advantage.
For the pair of
nodes closest to x
we can use this to calculate
the distance between them.
Very valuable.
Because I also want
to mention something.
If you have an integrand
which is rapidly oscillating,
or if you have two rapidly
oscillating functions
and you're multiplying
them together,
that integral will accumulate to
its final value at the position
where the two oscillating
functions are oscillating
at the same frequency.
That's the stationary
phase point.
And this is also
a wonderful thing,
because if you can
figure out where
the things you're
multiplying together
are oscillating at
the same frequency,
your integral becomes a number.
No work ever.
And that's a useful thing.
OK, so the stationary
phase method
enables you to use this
in a really fantastic way.
And it's a little bit like
Feynman's path integral idea,
that you can calculate a
complicated thing by evaluating
an integral over
a convenient path
as opposed to integrating
overall space,
because everything
that you care about
comes from a stationary phase.
Quantum mechanics is
full of oscillations,
classical mechanics
doesn't have oscillations,
and the two meet at the
stationary phase point.
Now we're going to use
these ideas to calculate
useful stuff for quantum
mechanical vibrational wave
functions.
The shapes of psi of x
gets exponentially damped,
but it extends into the
classically forbidden
e less than v of x regions.
The wave function,
if we have potential
and we have a wave
function, that wave function
is going to not go
to 0 at the edge
but it's going to have a tail.
And that tail goes
to 0 at infinity.
And so there is some amplitude
where the particle isn't
allowed to be, classically.
And that's where
tunneling comes in.
But the important thing,
the important insight
is that there are no nodes
in the classically forbidden
region.
There is only exponential
decay towards 0,
and if you've chosen the
wrong value of the energy,
in other words a place where
there is no eigenfunction,
the wave function in the
classically forbidden region
will usually go to infinity.
Either over here or
over here, and says,
well, it's clearly
not a good function.
But there are no 0 crossings.
It's oscillating
in e greater than v
of x, the classically
allowed region.
The number of nodes
is v. So we can
have a v equals 0 function that
just goes up and goes down,
no internal nodes.
v equals one, it crosses
zero right in the middle.
And we have the even oddness.
Even v, even function.
Odd v, odd function.
For an even function you have a
relative maximum at x equals 0,
and for an odd
function you have a 0.
And the opposite
further derivatives.
The outer lobes,
the ones on the ends
just before the particle
encounters the classical wall,
you get the maximum amplitude.
And so you can draw cartoons
which look sort of like that.
Most of the valuable stuff is
at the other turning point.
And there's
oscillations in between,
but often you really care
about these two outer lobes.
That's a pretty
good simplification.
Now there's a nice picture
in McQuarrie on page 226
which shows, especially
for psi squared,
that the nodes are pretty big.
But they're not as big for
relatively low quantum numbers
as I've implied.
But at really high
quantum numbers
we have a thing called the
correspondence principle.
And the corresponding principle
says that quantum mechanics
will do what classical
mechanics does
in the limit of high
quantum numbers.
And in the limit of
high quantum numbers
essentially all the amplitude
is at the turning points.
And in classic
mechanics the particle
is moving fast in the middle,
and stops and turns around,
and essentially all
of the amplitude
is at the turning point.
So this is nice.
Now we're getting
into Bobism territory,
because I'm really
going to show you
how to calculate
whatever you need using
these semi-classical ideas.
We have the
probability envelope.
Psi star of x psi
of x, and we're
going to have both of these
having the same quantum
number, dx.
So this is the probability of
finding the particle near x
in a region with dx.
And this is the same thing
as dx over v classical.
It's not the same thing, there
is a constant here, sorry.
This probability
density that you want
is basically 1 over
the classical velocity.
And I demonstrated
that when I walked
across the room, when I
walked fast in the middle
and slow the outside.
And you get the probability,
you get this constant,
by saying, OK, how long did it
take for me to go from one end
to the other?
And comparing that,
how long it took
for me to go in some
differential position.
You get this constant
in a simple way.
v classical is equal to p
classical over the mass,
over the mu.
But we know the function
for p classical.
We have 1 over mu times
2 mu e, minus v of x.
So we know the
velocity everywhere,
and there's nothing terribly
hard about figuring that out.
And now we want to know what
this proportionality constant
is.
And so for that we say the
time to go from x to x plus dx,
over the time to go
from x minus to x plus.
Because what's
happening, the particle
is going back and
forth inside this
well and so this is the time
it takes to go one pass,
and this is the
time it takes to go
through the region of interest.
And so this ratio
is the probability.
And so we have the probability
moving from left turning point
the right turning
point, and we want
to know the probability
in that interval.
And so that's just dx over
v classical at x, over tau,
over 2.
Because tau is the period, and
we have half of the period,
and so it's all together.
I'm going to skip a little step,
because it's taking too long.
Psi star psi dx is equal
to k over 2 pi squared,
e minus v of x square of dx.
Now so if we know the potential,
and we know the energy,
and we know the force
constant we can say,
well, this is the
probability and--
but this is the probability
of the semi-classical
representation of
psi star psi dx at x.
Now this is oscillating,
and this is not.
So what we really want to know--
here's the-- if we have
psi star whoops, slow down.
This is oscillating and
what we've calculated before
is something that looks
sort of like that.
And if we multiply
by 2 we have a curve
that goes to the maximum
of all these oscillations.
The envelope psi star
psi has the form.
We've multiplied by
2, and so we end up
getting 2k over pi squared,
e minus v of x square root.
Now you might say, well these
are complicated functions,
why should I bother with them?
But if you wanted
anything starting
from the correct solution
to the harmonic oscillator,
using the Hermite
polynomials, there's
a whole lot more overhead.
Notice also this is a
function of x, not xi.
This is the overlap
function, it's
the curve that touches the
maximum of all these things
and it's very useful if you
want to know the probability
of finding the system anywhere.
And we get the node spacing
from the equation h over p of x.
And now here comes
something really nice.
It's called the semi-classical
quantization interval.
If we have any one
dimensional potential,
and we're at some
energy, we'd like
to be able to know how many
levels are at that energy,
or below.
Or where are the energy levels?
And we get that from this
really incredible thing.
We want to know that--
this is the difference
between nodes.
Right?
And now if we would
like to know x
minus to x plus and some energy,
we can replace lambda of x by h
over p of x.
And so we get p of x at
that energy over h dx.
pdx, that's called
an action integral.
Now I have to tell
a little story.
When I was a senior
at Amherst College
we had a oral exam for
whether my thesis was
going to be accepted or not.
And one of my examiners asked
me, what is the unit of h?
Well, it's energy times time.
And he wouldn't stop.
He said no, I want
something else.
It's called action.
Momentum times position.
This is an action integral.
And so anyway
that's just a story.
I spent a half an hour,
and I was damn stubborn.
I was not-- you know, it
was energy times time.
But that is much
more insight here
and that's maybe
why I got so excited
about this sort of an integral.
If we want to know if
we have an eigenvalue
this integral has to
be equal to h over
2 times the number of nodes.
Well it's pretty simple.
So we can adjust
e to satisfy this.
Or if we wanted to know
how many energy levels are
at an energy below
the energy we've
chosen we evaluate
this integral,
and we get a number like 13.5.
Well, it means there are 13
energy levels below that.
Now often you want to know
the density of states,
the number of energy
levels per unit energy,
because that turns out to
be the critical quantity
in calculating many
things you want to know.
And you can get that from the
semi-classical quantization.
We're close to the end, I just
want to say where we're going.
We have classical pictures
and I really, really
want you to think about
these classical pictures
and use them rather
than thinking, well,
I'm going to have my cell
phone program to evaluate
all the necessary stuff.
And there are certain
things you want
to remember about this
semi-classical picture.
And now we have the ability to
calculate an infinite number
of integrals involving
harmonic oscillator
functions in certain operators.
Well, la-di-da.
Why do we want them?
Well one of the
things we want is
to be able to calculate
the probability
of a vibrational transition.
That's called a
transition element,
and that's an easy
thing to calculate.
Another thing we want
to do is to say, well,
nature screwed up.
This oscillator isn't harmonic,
there's anharmonic term,
and I would like to know
what is the contribution
of a constant times x
cubed in the potential
to the energy levels.
And that's called
perturbation theory.
Or I want to have many
harmonic oscillators
in a polyatomic molecule,
they talk to each other,
and I want to calculate
the interactions
between these
harmonic oscillators
affect the energy level.
Remember, when we have
a separable Hamiltonian
we can just write the
energy levels as the sum
of the individual Hamilton.
And then there's
coupling terms, and we
deal with those but
perturbation theory.
There's all sorts of
wonderful things we do.
But we're going to consider
these magical operators,
a creation and annihilation
operator, where a star--
a dagger operating
on psi v gives
the square root of v plus
one, times psi v plus 1.
And a dagger operating on v
gives the square root of v--
let's write it--
I mean a non-dagger
gives v square root times
psi, v minus 1.
And that x is equal to a plus
a dagger times a constant.
And so all of a sudden we
can evaluate all integrals
involving x, or powers of x, or
momenta, or powers of momenta
without thinking.
Without ever looking
at a function.
And I guarantee you
that this is embodied
in the incredible amount
of work done wherever
we pretend almost every
problem is a harmonic
oscillator in disguise.
Because these a's
and a daggers enable
you to generate
everything without ever
converting from x to xi, without
ever looking at an integral.
It's all just a
manipulation of algebra.
And it's not just convenient,
but there's insight
and so this is what
I want to convey.
That you will get
tremendous insight.
Maybe, maybe I sold
you on semi-classical,
and I don't apologize for that
because that's very useful.
But the next lecture, when
you get the a's and a daggers,
it'll just knock your socks off.
OK, that's it.